police investigating the deadly fashion
show mall shooting on new year's eve
have made an interesting connection
thanks for staying with us here at 6 30.
i'm denise valdez i'm kirstjen joyce
detectives have connected a suspect to
another case christian castro is with
those details these two people walking
across those are our victims correct yes
they are surveillance video shown in
court from the deadly new year's eve
shooting at the fashion show las vegas
clarice yamaguchi a 66-year-old tourist
from hawaii died when the passenger gets
out
he drafts the females first and a
struggle ensues
the victim's husband sees this and goes
over to try and tackle the suspect or
the passenger
when that happens
the passenger fires all around 18 year
old jordan ruby and 20 year old jasoni
carter both sat quietly as metro
detectives explained what led up to the
murder and the separate crime carter was
involved in at the encore back in
november in november during the car stop
there was body cam video yes the driver
of that vehicle was someone identified
as sony carter
and then
it appears he was wearing a similar the
same or similar sweatshirt that the
perpetrator is wearing
the judge also hearing jail audio
recordings but not played for the
courtroom during the second phone call
he indicates that mr ruby indicates that
he came to las vegas for the purpose of
robbing people on new year's
both carter and ruby remain behind bars
with no bail and are scheduled to be
back in court in 30 days christian casa
is live local now